hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to be answering the
question from one of my readers Becky
who has developed a baby blanket car
seat cover that is unique but very
simple to make and she's wondering if
she should go apply for a provisional
patent or not in what protection that
gives her so Becky I'm not a lawyer so
we should definitely go talk to one but
here is my understanding and hopefully
it can help you first of all to apply
for any kind of pattern you have to make
sure that the product is not yet
commercially available so we have to do
it before you start selling your product
if you've already started selling your
product then you can only file a patent
on the changes that you've made some new
improvements to it second original
patent gives you one year international
coverage for your idea across every
market and I believe in some
circumstances you can also extend it to
another year but you basically have that
first year to figure out is my product
commercially viable or not because a
original patents a lot cheaper than
going for a full pot so once you've had
that year to figure out if you're going
to go for the full pot or not you have
to decide then which markets you want to
get a patent it so each country has
their own process and there's a cost
involved to get in a patent in each
country so that's get very expensive to
have full international coverage because
you have to apply for so many different
individual patents at the end of the day
you have to figure out is it worth the
time and cost to get this thing going
because people can still talk to your
idea and as part of your patent you have
to explain exactly how you create your
product so it's really easy to rip off
for you as an entrepreneur you would
then have to go and enforce the pattern
and that's usually the biggest stumbling
block for a lot of business owners
people will still top your idea but you
have to then go hire lawyers to enforce
it and say you're copying my patent and
you know
to do this so usually it's not worth it
for the entrepreneurs to have that kind
of expense to go and hire lawyers to do
it but you do have one year original
patent status for international coverage
but hopefully gives you some time to
figure out if your product is going to
sell or not and if it's worth taking
that next step so hopefully that helps
gives you some ideas to work with if you
guys liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below and I'd also love to
hear your thoughts and feedback if you
want to leave a comment and stay tuned
for the next episode
you